but nevada is ranked second to last when
it comes to covet 19 vaccinations so far
state officials though are blaming the
federal government for not
sending enough doses of the vaccine but
it turns out
many doses are just sitting in freezers
in nevada
the i-team's vanessa murphy has been
digging into the numbers for us and
joins us now live with more here at six
vanessa denise
state officials point to challenges like
a lack of communication
and resources from the federal
government but
it's still not clear why other states
are vaccinating more people
than nevada and as of noon today the
state reported that
40 percent of doses were not yet used
this is a huge system as you can
appreciate
the federal government is involved the
state government is involved the local
health districts are involved
the cdc lists nevada as second to last
in the nation
and the number of doses received from
the federal government
on monday governor steve seselek sent
this letter to the acting health and
human services secretary
asking why the same day the cdc also
reports the
state as third to last in administering
the vaccine
meaning it lags behind in vaccinating
nevadans
you're sitting in a freezer and there is
a scheduled plan
in every county to use these doses
candice mcdaniel who's heading the
vaccine rollout says as of monday
the state has received nearly 287
thousand doses from the federal
government
and 60 percent were administered that
leaves close to 150
000 not yet used the i-team asked what
needs to be done to speed up the process
and get those doses into the arms of
nevadans
this could be it was a delivery that was
just made
a lot of counties have a week of
scheduled
events that are essentially as you've
seen sort of
already full of participants who have
signed up
and so i think what we need to keep in
mind is that there's a plan
for all of these doses according to the
state's covit 19 task force the federal
government has sent about 36 thousand
doses a week
while the goal is to administer 18
thousand a day
no word on whether the federal
government will increase the amount of
doses sent to nevada each week
and state officials say they don't get
much notice
it's incredibly difficult to only know a
week ahead of time
to stand up mass vaccination events
and especially for those mega
vaccination sites like the cashman
center if they don't know how many doses
they'll receive it's difficult
to set up those appointments joe mohler
will have more on that coming up
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now